what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today it looks like
we could possibly have some details
about the upcoming MCU X-Men film and I
am specifically talking about the film a
movie not when the X-Men are gonna pop
up here and there but the specific X-Men
titled film that is going to be coming
to the MCU that will have the X-Men team
today we have a new report from screen
geek and they claim to know some plot
details about that first X-Men film who
the possible team could be and even a
slight connection to World War Hulk
which of course we've been talking about
a lot lately since She-Hulk so blatantly
and obviously set up events for another
Hulk film now World War Hulk is the
rumored plot for the upcoming Hulk film
but I for one since the X-Men are coming
to the MCU would really really love to
see a Hulk vs Wolverine movie I doubt
we'll get that anytime soon but anytime
I hear X-Men and the Hulk together
that's what I hope for and that's what I
think of but let's dive into the screen
geek article talk about what it says
break it down and of course if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest Marvel news so at screengeek.net
we go to the article and the title is
exclusive plot details for X-Men MCU
movie revealed and this was posted
yesterday September 20th and we won't
read the whole thing because not all of
it applies to what we're talking about
but let's start with the beginning and
go up to the X-Men report it starts by
saying when Disney finally got the movie
rights back to various Marvel characters
in 2017 after the company's deal to
acquire 20th Century Fox many fans
thought that the X-Men would be the
first on the list to get a reboot fast
forward to 2022 and an X-Men movie has
yet to be announced some thought that an
update would come during this year's San
Diego Comic-Con or d23 but it never
happened although there is no release
date for Marvel's upcoming X-Men movie
we do have new plot details and here is
their official report all our sources
have told us that Marvel studios's
current plan is for the mcu's X-Men film
to be based on Joss whedon's astonishing
X-Men run astonishing X-Men was a comic
book series continuation of Grant
Morrison's new X-Men whedon's run began
in 2004 and ended in 2008. we'll talk
more about this in a bit but let's
finish what they state in the report
they continue to say it's unclear which
X-Men team the studio plans on using but
it's worth noting that the lineup in
that series was Cyclops and Emma Frost
who were the team leaders and also
included Beast Kitty Pride Wolverine and
Colossus that group was also featured in
various limited series including World
War Hulk X-Men and that is their report
it's not too big but it is something now
keep in mind this is not confirmed and
even if it was things can still change
there's a long time before we actually
get that X-Men film however I do believe
there is a big important Cyclops
connection here and I want to talk about
that before we dive into the actual
X-Men team and the story of the runs
that was mentioned in this article I
think Cyclops is going to play a very
very big role in the mcu's X-Men team
and I think Marvel has been teasing us
with that in a very very subtle and Sly
way if you've been keeping up with
Marvel news you know that Marvel Studios
released concept art for Miss Marvel for
Avengers con that was never actually put
in any episode of the series but the
concept art showed Avengers con and
somebody cosplaying as Cyclops
specifically Cyclops in his X-Men
uniform most of you have already heard
me mention this already but this
basically does confirm that an actual
team already exists in the MCU if it was
just Cyclops Cyclops on his own without
the team he wouldn't be wearing the
X-Men uniform nobody would be cosplaying
as an X-Men character if the X-Men
didn't exist then of course in the last
episode of She-Hulk while the credits
were rolling we saw pug and he was
looking at his shoes and he was looking
at the new Iron Man 3s and in the
background we saw a lot of other
superhero shoes as well and in the back
mixed with all of the other shoes on the
racks we saw very clearly some cyclop
shoes but here's the thing we know that
Marvel Studios doesn't ever do anything
unintentionally they put a lot of
thought into everything that they do so
I fully believe that this was very
intentional releasing the concept art
that showed Cyclops that was never
actually put in any of the episodes
teasing us of Cyclops and then again in
She-Hulk not just teasing us of Cyclops
but of Deadpool of cable of the thing
and many more superheroes marvel knows
exactly what they're doing which is why
I believe that Cyclops really is
probably in the MCU already and is going
to play a major role of the X-Men team
he's probably going to be Professor
Xavier's right hand man nothing new
there but I wouldn't be surprised if we
saw Cyclops before we saw Professor X
now they mentioned that the story could
be based off of Joss whedon's
astonishing X-Men run and this is
actually four different stories and two
of them were limited series now it's
worth noting that the series as a whole
ended in 2018 but this report
specifically talks about Joss whedon's
run now there's a lot that goes down
during these stories but there are a few
things that you need to know that could
very heavily play into the mcu's X-Men
Arc this could be a little example of
what we could be in for one is that this
story Joss Whedon wanted to be
independent of all of the other big
crossover stories from Marvel Comics
like House of M Civil War Avengers vs
the X-Men and so on so basically in this
story this particular story those events
never happened and we could be facing
something like that in the MCU if Secret
Wars kind of does a reset of the MCU
because that's a big question a lot of
people have right now have the X-Men
been around the entire time and if they
have how exactly have they not been
mentioned yet how have we not discovered
them how does Doctor Strange not know
about them or the previous sorcerer's
supreme or Wong hopefully this question
gets answered soon so perhaps this story
could be independent of current events
in the MCU perhaps doing a reboot but
the second thing that you need to know
is that this story does involve the
mutant cure we saw this storyline kind
of in X-Men the Last Stand the story
also includes Sentinels and defending
the world from an alien race now the
alien race is something that I could
definitely see happening along with the
Sentinels as well I think there could be
sort of a fusion of a sentinel slash
kind of an iron Legion type of thing we
know that armor Wars is going to be all
about when Tony Stark's technology his
Iron Man technology gets into the wrong
hands and if they're going to try and
keep the continuity of the MCU before
the X-Men happen in Phase 7 which I do
believe they should I don't think they
should reboot but if they keep it the
same this could be a great segue into
the Sentinels and as far as them
defending Earth from an alien race I
think a lot of that is about to go down
with secret Invasion I for one think
secret invasion is going to be a lot
bigger than we expect it to be and a lot
more important and tactful on the MCU
than we expect it to be as well I do
believe this will set up a lot of future
events that will take place that are
going to be pretty significant even
without the X-Men and the Fantastic Four
coming into the MCU I do believe the MCU
is about to change in a very very big
way the Multiverse is essentially about
to burst open technically it already did
at the end of Loki but with Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania introducing Kane
the conquer and probably more than one
variant of King and then Loki season 2
deep diving into the Multiverse it's all
about to explode then on top of that we
are diving into the supernatural side of
the MCU with blade hopefully Ghost Rider
we got that Donnie Blaze tease and
She-Hulk hopefully Johnny Blaze the
actual Ghost Rider is coming soon we
have the street level team with
Daredevil returning and born again and
the recent reports of the Punisher
returning and Jessica Jones so we have
that street level and then we're going
to have the cosmic side the remaining
Guardians of the Galaxy Nova Adam
Warlock Captain Marvel and hopefully a
lot of other really cool characters and
then of course we have the X-Men and the
Fantastic 4. I think the future is
bright and I wouldn't personally mind
Cyclops kind of being our main leader of
the X-Men when they first get introduced
and I wouldn't mind seeing the X-Men
help defend Earth from an alien threat
it's probably too soon when they first
get introduced to go on and start
talking about a mutant cure but hey
that's just my opinion let me know what
you think about this in the comments
down below would you like this if this
ends up being true let me know down
below please don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all MCU news for live updates
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof